be a great ally to fat people here are
some things you can do when you go to
the doctor encourage them to do the
following things eliminate any weight or
bmi cut off policies stop using the bmi
completely because it is ineffective and
racist get medical equipment that will
actually work for fat patients like
blood pressure cups that fit and won't
give a false high reading because
they're too tight set up their office in
a way that makes it usable for fat
people like putting chairs without arms
in every room when you go to a clothing
store tell them to expand their size
range it does not matter what their size
range currently is tell them to expand
it
if you work in education get in touch
with the health and pe departments ask
them if they have anything in their
curriculum that involves students
weighing themselves counting calories or
using the bmi in any capacity if they do
educate them on how all of these
practices lead to eating disorders and
ask them to stop
that's a lot of things to do
what would be the purpose of that oh to
be an ally
to fat people